on inside the NBA it seems like you guys
have a dream job you know you get to sit
there you get to hang out you get to
talk about basketball it's fun it seems
like it's a pretty sweet job yeah I
would say it's a dream job you know
especially for you know God will grew up
as a fan yeah but at times which is
crazy Charles I'm gonna retire I'm gonna
stop Charles Barkley says he's gonna
stop I'm like do we work one day a week
we just we're only on Thursdays I'm like
that is retirement yeah yeah gives up a
job that only works one day a week but
him yeah he he's quite the character
you also have Shaq helping you guys out
yeah I love this I was watching when
this happened it was around
Christmastime you almost killed Shaq yes
do you remember this well see let's
explain it first before we show the clip
well Shaq likes to do practical jokes
yeah so he was like hey Kenny I think it
would be funny if you kind of like you
know when you run to the big board and
you describe what's plays going on have
this huge board behind me
he says I'll run behind you and then we
kind of race and we try to like bump
into each other something like wait a
minute
he's like 340 yeah he pumps it to me I'm
gonna just be flying the other way so I
said I got a trick for him and this was
the trick okay so this is what you did
let's take a look see here is
he was going out he tried to punch me
out
something could suck he doesn't even get
mad he doesn't even get mad he gets up
and goes I think we're gonna go viral
yeah all he cares about yeah he's that
that was impressive he's yeah that was a
good show
you